the marvel cinematic universe is filled
with mind-blowing camerawork and
staggering visual effects but there are
a handful of particularly powerful shots
that truly stand out as being some of
the most ambitious and successful ones
in the entire superhero extravaganza to
date let's take a look at some of the
Marvel movie shots that have helped to
define the franchise always angry the
avengers first true assembly scene mark
the exact moment the MCU became the
cinematic juggernaut its architects
always knew it would be that's my secret
captain
I'm always angry
but is transformation is a direct lead
into the squad finally taking shape
after five movies worth of build up to
battle what is arguably still the most
compelling villain of the MCU Loki when
people think back to the Avengers they
think about the shots and the bevy of
amazing scenes our follower passenger
Patrol
I am Man three's entire Air Force One
rescue scene is downright incredible
so narrowing it down to a single shot
was tough while there are several
examples of stunning cinematography on
display in the scene one narrowly rises
above the competition it's the shot of
Iron Man dashing down from a destroyed
Air Force One to save this entire crew
immediately after being told by Jarvis
like carrying them all would be an
impossibility from a visual imagery
perspective the shot contains all the
necessary elements of smoking Air Force
One in the distance a crew of people
screaming and flailing mid freefall and
a tiny golden red speck rocketing
towards them to save the day
this shot does an impeccable job of
conveying the stakes of the situation
before Iron Man defies all odds once
again with another stroke of brilliance
actually good team effort all around
goers guardians gather with guardians of
the galaxy james gunn crafted an action
film that had hearts and wit and the
shot of the group getting together to
form their own mini avengers pack was so
very satisfying the slo-mo dolly shot
that aligns this new unusual gang of
heroes is as spectacular as it is
subversive with each of the five looking
annoyed or bored or in the case of rocky
racoon tugging on a suit too tight
around his junk it's gritty lighting and
muted colors in an otherwise colorful
outerspace world gives us a sense our
heroes are walking toward that doom and
considering a couple of them a yawning
the R obviously not too busted up about
it that tracking shot considering how
the silly rating the first Avengers big
tracking shot was it's no surprise that
just we'd and opted to double dip and we
used a technique for the opening of age
of Ultron here he takes the idea to its
logical extreme reserving the whole
first minute of the film for a non-stop
assault on the sensors the camera moves
at a rip-roaring pace reintroducing you
to each avenger and the abilities they
bring to the team it's a near perfect
blend of pure spectacle and unspoken
character descriptions and there's an
icing on the cake a shot even finishes
with the whole team assembled striking a
pose together in midair that pays homage
to a
number of comic covers it's the ideal
way to open up an Avengers movie and
gets the audience ready for two hours of
high-octane over-the-top action the big
punch The Hulk vs. Hulkbuster fight
instantly became one of the most
anticipated MCU throwdowns of all time
and the height was certainly well
warranted the shot that really captures
the most epic moments is when the upper
hand flip flops back and forth between
Hulk and Iron Man in his Hulkbuster suit
the ultimate stalemate has reached when
green fist meets robot fist creating a
blast wave that breaks glass and sends
people flying this as intense as punches
come and is captured at an extra-wide
angle that really helps translate the
enormity of the two titans not only is
it a very cool shot on a technical level
but for Marvel fans it's just an amazing
sight to see Hulk and Iron Man going at
it on the big screen
pistol hop maybe it's the kinetic energy
of the camera sweeping beside ant-man
that makes a moment so special but the
shot of the title character running on
the surface of a gun immediately dodging
his bullet at a literal point-blank
range is superb
it's that brand of absurdity that
perfectly summarizes why the shot works
it revels in its craziness while also
giving Scott Lang the heroic framing he
deserves however small that might be
Civil War as a tribute to Captain
America Civil War source material the
climatic wise shots of Cup fighting iron
- ripped directly from the comics in the
scene a cap charges at Stark deflecting
each and every repulsor blasts with his
shield until the two foes are inches
apart then the world slows to a crawl
isolating the visually stunning moment
when iron man unleashes one final
repulsor blasts directly onto the
surface of cap shield the blast reflects
off air and blazes to life filling the
screen with a light that could only be
achieved by the union of this
unstoppable force meeting the immovable
object there's no mystery why the shot
is a defining image of the film it's
representing it fulfills everything we
hoped this movie would be all within a
few frames kycilia says lingering escape
you can tell the director and storyboard
artist had a fun time thinking of the
various shots and Doctor Strange and the
one that really brings magic to the MCU
is kycilia says big sling ring escape
the mind-bending shot subliminally
reinforces one of dr. Strange's biggest
themes that everything's just a matter
of
effective the color grading leaves the
buildings of dull that is saturated gray
divided only by pitch black shadows
allowing us to perfectly track where the
Sorcerer's are distorting geography and
help us focus our attention on the
mystical glowing elements it's also
ridiculously busy yet super focused
allowing us to be overwhelmed by the
buildings consuming themselves in the
background while still letting us remain
fully concentrated on kycilia sis Ling
Ling escape fairy save last but not
least
spider-man homecoming introduce a
quintessential hero shots displaying a
protagonist challenging impossible odds
head-on in order to save the day there's
nothing quite as epic as seeing the teen
hero desperately clutching to his webs
to keep this fairy and all of his
passengers from drowning even though the
scene was spoiled in the film's trailers
it still represents the spider-man ethos
utter determination even in the absence
of hope this moment reminds us that
Spidey is always in it for the greater
good which is why he's one of the
greatest heroes thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]